20 years before the main story of Game
of Thrones
there was a great tournament held at the
castle of Harrenhal this was like the
biggest High School House body in
Westeros everyone was there drinking
feasting hanging out hooking up trading
secrets raising drama and all these
years later people are still talking
about what happened to those Knights who
got the most drunk who hooked up with
who who was plotting to overthrow the
government that sort of stuff we don't
know the details of much that happened
because we only learn of the tourney
through memory and rumor but we do hear
one mysterious story about the knight of
the Laughing tree in book 3 Meera Reed
tells bran stark the story it begins in
the neck a swampy region north of the
river lands the story follows a young
crannogmen a young man from the neck and
though Meera never says his name it's
implied that the lad is a young Howland
Reed the father of Meera and Jojen from
his home in the neck
Collins traveled south to the Isle of
faces an island in the Riverlands sacred
to the old gods and inhabited by a
mysterious people called the green men
Callum stayed there through winter and
when he left he came to the castle of
Harrenhal where the great tournament was
beginning
Meera lists some of the people who were
there and again she doesn't say their
names but we can figure them out by
their titles and heraldry there's the
King Aerys Targaryen with his son the
dragon Prince Rhaegar because all this
takes place before Robert's rebellion
when the Targaryen still ruled Westeros
there are the white swords the
Kingsguard who'd come to welcome a new
brother to their ranks young Jaime
Lannister was about to join the
Kingsguard the storm Lord Robert
Baratheon was there and the Rose Lord
mace Tyrell but the great lion of the
rock Tywin Lannister didn't come he was
angry with Aerys for taking Jaime into
the Kingsguard and for refusing to marry
Rhaegar to Cersei Rhaegar instead
married Elia Martell she's here as well
so the young Howland from the neck sore
all these important people at this great
castle the Knights and banners the food
and laughter and he was excited to be a
part of it but as he was walking across
a field enjoying the day
and harming none he was attacked by
three young Squires there's a lot of
racism against the crannogmen of the
neck people call the mud men and frog
eaters
the Squires believed that this was a
dare world and the crannogmen howland
had no right to be there so they hit him
and kicked him and cursed him until he
was saved by a she-wolf Lyanna stark
Liana drove off the Squires with a
blunted sword and took howland back to
her tent to treat his wounds there
Howland met Lee and his brothers the
wild wolf Brandon Stark who dies before
Robert's rebellion so he isn't in the
show and the quiet wolf Eddard Stark and
the pup Benjen Stark they're all
teenagers back then Brandon's about 19
Ned was 18 Leonore about 15 and benjin
about 14 Howland was 16 or so Liana
insisted that Howland come and sit with
the Starks at the feast so that night he
ate and drank with the Northland and
took in the sights of the feast he saw
Prince Rhaegar sing a song so sad that
it made Liana cry and this is the first
mention of a connection between these
two and he saw a maid with laughing
purple eyes ashara dayne danced with the
Kingsguard and with Oberyn Martell and
Jon connington
and with Ned Stark after Ned got Brandon
to ask a sheriff at the dance cuz Ned
was too shy there are rumors of a
relationship between Ned and azshara
some say that Ned got a shara pregnant
others think it might have been Brandon
but whoever it was a year later ishara
had a stillborn child and her brother
Arthur was killed by Ned and Howland and
azshara committed suicide so we might
never know the truth
later at the feast Howlin spotted the
Squires who attacked him and saw they
each served a knight one of house Hey
one of house blunt and one of house pray
the stock suggested that Howland should
win back his honour by beating the
Knights in the tournament but Howland
wasn't much good at writing and jousting
and thought it'd just make a fool of
himself that night he went out by the
lake and looks to the Isle of faces and
prayed to the old gods of the north
later at the tournament the Knights of
hey Blount and Frey did well in the
jousting but late one afternoon a new
challenger
appeared a mystery night with his name
and face hidden identified only by a
weirwood tree with a laughing face
painted on the shield this knight of the
Laughing tree challenged the hey blunt
and for eight nights and defeated each
of them at jousting
he gave them back their horses and armor
only after the Knights punished the
Squires for having attacked Howland Reed
and so the chronic man's honour was
restored and all the crowd cheered for
the mystery Knight King Aerys though was
not a fan Ares was mad and paranoid and
he saw the tree Knight as his enemy so
he sent his son Rhaegar to find out who
the tree Knight was but apparently all
they ever found was the Knights painted
shield hanging in a tree and so the
story of the knight of the Laughing tree
ends with a mystery who was the knight
the story leads us to believe that the
night was Howland Reed and Howland would
fit some of the details were given about
the night the knight said to be short of
stature and Howland was small and the
knight is clad in ill-fitting armor made
up of bits and pieces as Howland would
have been if he had to scrounge armor
together to compete but we're also told
pretty clearly that Howland isn't good
at writing and jousting he feared he'd
make a fool of himself at the entered
the tourney in the story mirror suggests
that the old gods or the green men of
the Isle heard Howland's prayers by the
lake and gave strength to his arm so he
could win back his honor which is nice
enough for a fairy tale but Game of
Thrones isn't the sort of world where
the weak can beat the strong just by
being righteous and brave and believing
in themselves Littlefinger learned that
in his jewel with Brandon Stark as for
the old gods they really don't seem to
be the benevolent divine intervention
sort of type but they're more into blood
sacrifice or that heavy Old Testament
sort of [ __ ] would they really bother
answering the prayers of a teenager who
wants to win a joust that just isn't
consistent with what we've seen of gods
and magic in this series the other
important reason why the knight probably
isn't Howland is because brand tells us
that he thinks the knight is Howland
what sort of mystery is that if we're
immediately given the right answer
usually the way mysteries work in this
series is that were given an obvious
answer at first like that Jon Snow is
the bastard son of Ned Stark
or that Jon Arryn was poisoned by the
Lannisters but later we find out that
the truth is something more complex that
Jon Snow is actually lyanna stark's son
and that Jon Arryn was actually poisoned
by Lysa a little finger so what's the
deeper more complex truth to the mystery
of the knight of the Laughing tree when
Mira tells this story
Jojen seems really surprised the bran
hasn't already heard the tale from his
father Ned this may suggest that Ned or
someone close to him who was the mystery
knight maybe it was one of the stark
boys benjin Ned and Brandon each would
have made a much better night than
Howland Reed because the stalks were
trained to ride five so they wouldn't
have needed divine intervention to
plausibly win a few jousts Brandon
especially was said to be good at riding
and fighting and he was described as
hot-blooded and rash a gallant fool so
standing up for Howland by riding in the
Tony fits pretty well with what we know
of his personality there are problems
with Brandon though because Brandon was
tall so even at the age of 19 he might
not have fit the mystery Knights small
stature also it doesn't make much sense
for Brandon to enter the tourney as a
mystery night because he later rides in
the tourney as himself why would he have
chosen to ride in disguise in the first
place so another possibility is Ned he
was younger and shorter than Brandon so
he might fit the knight small stature
and Ned riding for Howland Reed an
attorney might help explain how Howland
became such a loyal friend Senedd
however even as a young man Ned's
described as solemn and somber he's
responsible and reserved with a certain
distaste for the pageantry of Tony's
joining in a joust as a mystery knight
with a shield of a laughing tree is not
exactly Ned's style he's not so showy in
theatrical so Ned just isn't a great fit
for the knight of the Laughing tree
either maybe it was benjin benjin was 14
or younger than so he'd fit the Knights
short stature and benjin was the one to
offer Howland
armored and a horse to write an attorney
so he was enthusiastic about someone
competing but on the other hand at 14
years of age Ben was very young and
there's no suggestion in the text that
he was particularly good at riding or
fighting or jousting so he doesn't seem
a very likely night either all three
stock boys could maybe be the tree
Knight but none very convincing
a more likely answer to this mystery is
Lyanna stark at the teenage girl Lyanna
could fit the night short stature and
ill-fitting armor and she certainly has
the motivation to help Howard she was
the one to come to fend him in the first
place
competing in the tourney also fits well
with her personality he's described as
wild willful and boyish she's said to be
like aya and fighting to help out a
friend is exactly the sort of thing aya
would do leona being the knight also
adds a cool twist in having the knight
who everyone assumed to be a man turned
out to be a girl at one point in the
story meera describes the knights voice
booming through his helm
maybe the echo enos of the Knights
helmet helps disguise Liana's voice of
course it's questionable whether a 15
year old girl would be strong enough to
use a lance in a joust but in winds that
another 15 year old girl Elias and who
just so much that they call her lady
Lance a perfect president for Liana to
joust also further
we're told a bunch of times that Liana
was a very good horse rider Roose Bolton
says that Liana was half a horse and he
also says in the same paragraph that a
great gesture must be a great Horseman
Jaime Lannister agrees thinking that
jousting is three-quarters horsemanship
so the text directly links the idea of
riding being important for jousting to
the fact that Liana was great at riding
a pretty strong hint that Liana could
have done well an attorney so Liana fits
the knight of the Laughing tree quite
well but the most convincing reasons for
why Liana was probably the mystery
knight relate to how this would fit with
the broader story it's very very
interesting
there were specifically told that King
Aerys sent his son Rhaegar to find and
unmask the knight of the Laughing tree
because
later in this same tournament prince
rhaegar publicly crowns Liana as his
queen of love and beauty and later he
runs away with Liana which leads to
Robert's rebellion the deaths of Rhaegar
and Lyanna and the birth of Jon Snow
maybe the whole fateful relationship
between Liana and Rhaegar all began when
Rhaegar was sent to find the knight of
the Laughing tree we're told that no one
found the knife but what if Rhaegar did
and chose to keep Leanna's secret maybe
he was impressed by her boldness in
writing an attorney we already know
Liana wept at the beauty of kreega's
harp earlier maybe they hit it off they
say there's nothing like a tourney to
make the blood run hot so maybe some
words were whispered in a tenth of a
night words or kisses maybe more maybe
this is how Liana and Rhaegar ice and
fire first fell in love it's also very
interesting that the place where all
this happens and the place where Rhaegar
later quote-on-quote
abduct Liana is so close to the Isle of
faces there are theories that Rhaegar
and Lyanna secretly got married on the
Isle of faces with the weirwoods all
round so that psychic bran can later
have a vision of the wedding and our
plus l equals J can finally be revealed
this is all very speculative but it fits
so well with what we know and paints a
beautiful picture of a tragic love story
between Lyanna stark and rhaegar
targaryen a story that all begins with
the knight of the Laughing tree so given
how well this all fits and given the
hints of leiana's writing ability and
personality
it seems pretty likely that Liana is our
mystery Knight but we'll also have a
quick look at a crazier theory as we saw
in season 6 bran Starks greensight tree
magic psychic powers can lead to some
pretty wacky timey wimey shenanigans
like when he broke the mind of Hodor by
reaching through his past self to make
the Hodor of the present hold the door
some fans believe that something similar
could have happened with the knight of
the Laughing tree that when Howland
prayed to the old gods brand answers his
prayers from the future by walking into
past Howland taking the identity of the
mystery Knight
with a weirwood on his shield and using
some manner of old gods magic to win the
jousts and restore Howland's honor this
fits with some of the talk of magic
mentioned in mirrors story but it also
gives brand the chance to be something
he's always dreamed of being a knight
after Mira tells the story of the tree
Knight brand thinks that he'd love to be
a knight for a day a day would be enough
he thinks maybe with the magic of the
old gods he got that one day at the
tourney of Harrenhal so yeah the magic
time-travel theories are kind of
ridiculous but it has happened before
and these ideas can have some nice
thematic resonance though at the end of
the day it was probably Leona
we'll talk more about Leona and Rhaegar
before season 7 arrives but you might
like to go back and watch the season 6
episode 10 video Rhaegar and Lyanna and
john are explained about 14 minutes in
thanks for watching this video as ever
these theories and ideas mostly come
from the game of Thrones fan community
go check out Westeros org and the sub
reddits thanks to the translators for
translating captions thanks to the miko
for use of his art and thanks to the
patrons who make LG of dex possible
including Paige Markus Stuart Natalie Wu
Jason gray jr. Walt Mayfield and history
of Westeros a podcast you should all go
check out desert link below Cheers